[Musik]
dort wird ihnen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]
diese geschichte beginnt mit dem ende
neben der trauer bedeutet ein todesfall
für die hinterbliebenen nicht selten
auch viel ärger im oktober verstarb man
nach langer krankheit
die erbfolge ist sehr kompliziert seit
seinem tod kämpfe ich mit familie
formalitäten dem papierkram den banken
auf kosten meiner gesundheit
für mich ist dieser brief eine botschaft
regeln sie ihre angelegenheiten mit
ihrer unterschrift zu lebzeiten sprechen
sie mit ihren kindern die
hinterbliebenen werden friedlicher
liegen
das schreibt uns eine zuschauerin
schätzungsweise 76 milliarden franken
wurden der schweiz letztes jahr vererbt
aber es geht selten nur ums geld sondern
meist um emotionen
[Musik]
ballett chor der aus lausanne findet
keinen frieden mehr seit ihre mutter
gestorben ist
niemand hat sie benachrichtigt zumindest
nicht gleich oder zu spät
sie konnte nicht einmal an der
beerdigung teilnehmen
polit wurde in den 40er jahren als
uneheliches kind geboren und hat ihren
platz in der familie nie gefunden ihren
vater hat sie nicht gekannt
wenn ich an früher denke war ich bloß
eine bürde die man mitschleppt und nach
der schule hieß es werden wir sie los
und haben unseren frieden
das empfinde ich unglücklicherweise seit
vielen jahren ich war so etwas wie das
schwarze schaf oder die person die den
rest der familie störte ich habe mich
von meiner mutter nie angenommen gefühlt
als ihre mutter 2012 statt die polit
nichts überhaupt nichts
nicht das kleinste erinnerungsstück
[Musik]
polit war drei jahre alt als ihre mutter
heiratete aus dieser ehe entstammt ihr
halbbruder beim tod der mutter hätten er
und polit sich den besitz der mutter
teilen müssen
so steht es im gesetz aber poland bekam
nichts
sie nahm sich einen anwalt
[Musik]
das schlechte einvernehmen mit meiner
mutter ist wieder hochgekommen
ich wollte einfach wissen ob sie
vielleicht doch eine winzige geste mir
gegenüber gemacht hat war sie mich doch
hatte bevor sie geheiratet hat das ziel
war nicht zu erfahren ob ich zwei
franken bekomme oder zwei franken 50
dass sie wahre anzuerkennen dass ich
existiere das war für mich wichtig als
erbin anerkannt zu werden würde das
vielleicht das gefühl nicht
dazuzugehören wieder gutmachen
es lässt sich nicht alles mit geld
regeln das geld das geld erlaubt einem
etwas zu tun
sowas comics zu kaufen ich es tue
meine team und struppi sachen es ersetzt
aber niemals die liebe einer mutter zu
ihrem kind
diese geschichte hat bei colette einen
bitteren nachgeschmack hinterlassen
sie sucht nach spuren aus ihrem alten
leben ich suche postkarten vom
milchladen und vom brunnen mit der alten
müllerin
haben sie etwas in diesem stil
eine aufnahme der fabrik hier ist ein
foto von ganz oben bleibt vielleicht im
inneren drauf die kirche das kraftwerk
seit ihre mutter starb holt sie die
vergangenheit wieder ein
aber einen anwalt engagieren half nicht
weiter
da ist ja die schule das ist die
postkarte ja das ist die karte
zehntausend franken hat sie für den
anwalt ausgegeben sagt dann hat sie
alles hingeworfen und auf ihre ansprüche
und den rechtsweg verzichtet kommt es
zum prozess dann erhält man vielleicht
ein bisschen gerechtigkeit aber die
energie die man auf wendet das leid das
erlebte kommt wieder hoch das ist
ziemlich schmerzhaft was ist wieder
hochgekommen
eine zurückweisung eine zurückweisung
polit hätte juristisch noch weiter gehen
können aber sie hatte weder den mut noch
die kraft
lorraine ruf ist anwältin und
spezialistin für erbricht
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten für erben
wenn sie mit den vorkehrungen des
verstorbenen nicht einverstanden sind
die herabsetzung klage sie ermöglicht
den pflichtteil zu bekommen also dass
legale minimum
der erbe muss gegen die person klagen
die in seinen augen zu viel bekommen hat
eine andere möglichkeit ist die
aufhebung des testaments wenn man
annimmt ein testament sei unter dem
einfluss von furcht oder bedrohung
entstanden oder die person sei zu dem
zeitpunkt geistig umnachtet gewesen dann
kann man versuchen das testament
aufzugeben und eine erbfolge nach gesetz
zu erwirken
[Musik]
streitigkeiten enden dann hier vor
gericht
[Musik]
je nach kanton ist das bezirksgericht
die zuständige behörde für die eröffnung
von testamenten und für die aufstellung
von erscheinen hunderte von nachlassen
eröffnet marion er hat jedes jahr
sie ist leitende gerichtsschreiberin und
ersatz richterin am bezirksgericht
zürich ein testament kann viel über die
familiengeschichte erzählen
entweder wirklich sehr viel über ihn
schrieben und die schöne cisco hand und
wie gut dass alles immer gesehen und die
dankbar und auf der anderen seite
natürlich ausnahmefall zugeteilt wo dann
wirklich ein erblasser abrechnet in
ihrem fall wurde nicht abgerechnet aber
es ging etwas vergessen
marien und selin haben vor sieben jahren
ihre mutter verloren
cacau hat sie immer viel mehr angetan
kuchenbacken nach dem alten rezept ihrer
mutter ein erbe das sie sich neben
anderen dingen teilen
sie waren jung als ihre mutter starb und
völlig überfordert
es gab keine sorgen was die erbschaft an
ging das haus und all das
das lief ganz selbstverständlich mir war
nicht mal beim notar
aber wir waren wirklich enttäuscht von
unserer familie mütterlicherseits die in
frankreich liebt es gab ein konto auf
dem zwar keine große summe lag aber
dieses geld ging an die falsche person
es ging uns ums prinzip es verletzte
mich dass es ein anderer genommen hat
und das bekümmert uns weil es spannungen
in der familie gab die wir nicht wollten
wir wussten davon aber der fand es nicht
wir haben recherchen bei banken gemacht
und dieses geld nie gefunden
ich versuchte mit meiner familie
mütterlicherseits darüber zu reden
bis zu dem tag als ich zu ihnen ging und
sagte ich möchte vorwärts schauen dieses
konto muss jetzt an uns gehen
[Musik]
das geld an leiden bewirken kann also
das ist wirklich meine mama hätte das
nicht gewollt das trifft mich ihr vater
hat auf den rechtsweg verzichtet aber
die töchter aus dem freiburgischen über
sie wollten sich das geld nicht nehmen
lassen
sie kontaktierten einen anwalt in
frankreich dem herkunftsort ihrer mutter
unterdessen haben sie beschlossen dass
der juristische streit nichts bringt sie
wollen nicht noch mehr energie in dieser
angelegenheit hinein stecken
das ist gelungen das ist kaum und deiner
ja das ist kein motor
das ist auf mallorca ach ja freunde aus
frankreich
lieber erinnern sie sich an die schönen
zeiten als sie mit der verwandtschaft
der mutter noch ferien machten
das hat ihr beim akkordeon spielen
irgendwann habt ihr alle drei gespielt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine solche erbschaft kann sehr wehtun
das ist eine große enttäuschung wir
stehen uns alle sehr nahe vor allem der
schweizer teil der familie
[Musik]
mütterlicherseits gab es schon höhen und
tiefen aber damit konnten wir umgehen
aber uns war dieser teil der
verwandtschaft auch sehr wichtig das
hätten wir gerne bewahrt
[Musik]
die erbschaft der familie geschah ist
eigentlich ein klassischer fall die
hälfte des besitzers der verstorbenen
geht an den vater seine beiden töchter
syrien und selin bekommen die andere
hälfte also je einen viertel des erbes
[Musik]
das war uns so egal wirklich wir waren
am boden zerstört die welt blieb stehen
das erbe war nicht unsere sorge
ich erinnere mich dass die gemeinde eine
woche danach blumen gebracht hat ich
sehe uns drei noch am tisch sitzen und
sagen also bitte geht jetzt formalitäten
haben uns nicht gekümmert wir hatten
auch keinen erbschein aber das spielte
keine rolle
es ging uns schlecht ja aber man muss
schon sagen die fristen danach die muss
man einhalten
wir waren immer mit großer verspätung
dran wichtige briefe flüge erst als ich
schon beantwortet hätten sein müssen
ich glaube werden glück es war wirklich
immer haarscharf an der grenze
wir hätten sonst große schwierigkeiten
bekommen mittlerweile haben sich die
zwei jungen frauen mit der familie ihrer
mutter versöhnt eine emotionale geste
ihrer großmutter am grab der mutter hat
viel dazu beigetragen
anita von büren erlebte mit behörden und
formalitäten viel unerfreuliches sie und
ihre schwester waren schlichtweg
überfordert als die mutter starb
diese überforderung macht er aus einer
erbschaft eine schuldenfalle
die leidensgeschichte fing bereits mit
der erkrankung der mutter an
minute hätte es der relativ stark
fortschritten die inhalte regenerative
frankreich wo körperlich komplett in den
ich reden kann sagt bewegend wie ich
hätte gar nicht mehr in der mache
die krankheit ihrer mutter selber
verschlimmerte sich stetig die
pflegekosten nahmen zu und belasteten
die ganze familie
meine größte tiefpunkt es in freiheit
das nicht nur meine ganze gestalt von
der nothilfe außerdem fertigung das habe
er abgelehnt
sie hat in oberhof mit diesem geld ließ
sich die pflege knapp finanzieren
dann stellte die ausgleichskasse
plötzlich rückforderungen oder in
gestanden ist aber ich werde noch
jahrzehnte bevor die hilflose 16 uhr
tickt erhöht hatte
die kranke mutter hätte über 18.000
franken an die ausgleichskasse
zurückbezahlen müssen nicht mehr so
massiv dass das 80
bewusste und dem irgendwann ist man
durch den oscar dass die behörde wird er
als held war ja die gleiche chance
eigentlich hilflos eine beteiligung des
kontrollierten die beiden schwestern
glaubten an einen fehler von der
ausgleichskasse hörten sie nichts mehr
[Musik]
wenige monate später starb ihre mutter
hätten sich gemeldet und ausgesagt mobil
also was ich glauben als ich es mit tom
erzählt und männer also wiederum die
jetzt vier monate später ist dann hat
der vfb profis zurück dass ich noch
einen vorteil ich hoffe um mit
gesprächen heck und die forderung auf
die führung und gibt die forderung von
18.000 franken gingen nun an die
schwestern über als erbinnen mussten sie
bezahlen
für diese ist das emotional was er
sämtliche antreten und dann mich sehr
geehrt zurückzahlen
meine finger und in die finger und ja
wenn wir nach auch jetzt einfach zeit
und ich sage okay aber auch kraft und
man muss sich ihre situation mit relativ
niedrigen fordern nicht nach und wo man
nicht welches zuständig ist was man isst
schwierig ist beendet war im kapitel
hoffe und gehe mit der umstieg zwischen
ehe und hilflosenentschädigung also
danke mama das durchschnittliche liter
beförderte cm das militär situation und
sie
[Musik]
den beiden schwestern passierte das
wovor sich viele fürchten sie erbten
ahnungslos schulden
das gesetz ist in diesem fall eindeutig
waren mit werk schafft mit slot dann
erbt man nur alles vermögen sondern über
neue schulden über buchstaben ist
internet und dann hofft tut man mit dem
eigenen vermögen
zusätzlich kann der erbe will unbedingt
tätig werden und dann so genannte push
logische erklärung die zuständige
behörde gehen wir ins wohnzimmer das ist
die wohnung meiner mutter sie muss
schnell geräumt werden
deshalb aber ich sie kommen lassen
könnten sie bitte sämtliche familiären
gegenstände schätzen dies mutter ist vor
kurzem gestorben und sie und ihre
geschwister müssen nun den nachlass
aufteilen
dies ist ein bulgare papier messer
irgendwo muss eine punkt sei die
erbschaft vor der erbschaft damit sich
niemand übervorteilt fühlt und die
anteile der brüder und schwestern
gerecht aufgeteilt sind bartl den
experten eines auktionshauses die
wertgegenstände der mutter zu schätzen
eine neutrale begutachtung die streit
und missgunst beim teilen verhindern
soll
schweizer silberbesteck ohne monogamie
ohne ist es leichter zu verkaufen
ich höre ihnen zuerst ziele und zu sehen
was sie wünschen
verstehen sie sich gut oder weniger gut
das teilen es ist der moment wo alte
feindseligkeiten hochkommen
man muss die situation so gut wie
möglich verstehen um geeignete mittel
und wege vorschlagen zu können
februar in der firma proc werner p g hat
da so seine tricks wenn doch ich schlage
dem irgendwoher die ausgewählten dinge
in die hand zu nehmen und sie mit ihrem
namen beschriftet in eine ecke zu
stellen
sie sollen sich vorstellen wie es wäre
wenn sie es besitzen wenn man ein bild
oder eine uhr abhängt oder eine lampe
bewegt stellt man sich nämlich die frage
möchte ich das bei mir zu hause haben
oder nicht wir stellten uns die frage
nach den werten bilder und der
bekanntheit der künstler
das ist dann doch ein genfer das könnte
interessant sein für einen verkauf in
genf er hat einen gewissen wert
dafür werde ich ihnen später nummeriert
es inventar geld wir machen eine
schätzung
das wird ein paar hundert franken wert
sein das ist ganz offensichtlich lab ag
wir freuen uns die dinge bei den anderen
geschwistern zu hause zu sehen denn wir
besuchen uns oft wir sähen es gerne wenn
mama sachen an einen neuen ort ein neues
leben an
das wärmt uns das netz und macht uns
glücklich
uns wurde klar dass wir nicht die ganze
wohnung übernehmen können das geht nicht
wir haben alle unsere eigenen blut
gegenstände
wir können zwar dinge die wir haben
durch diese ersetzen aber eben nicht
alles einen teil werden wir verkaufen
während p&g schätzt und verkaufte
erbstücke ihm gehört das auktionshaus of
the board in genf das angesehene
auktionshaus ist eine wahre schatzkammer
regelmäßig werden hier nachlasse von
wohlhabenden persönlichkeiten
versteigert heute findet eine große
auktion stand eines der teuersten bilder
die zum verkauf stehen ist dieses das
ist ein bild aus dem nachlass lavanchy
des gründers von adia internet besitzer
des château de bono die ernten
verstanden sich sehr gut und die dinge
waren ganz klar festgelegt
dieser nachlass läuft gut obwohl es
wertvolle objekte sind das ist nicht
selbstverständlich denn oft gilt je mehr
geld desto mehr probleme
in diesem fall hatten wir das glück dass
wir unsere gutachten in ruhe machen
konnten und uns nicht von anfang an
schuhen mit zugeständnissen und
erklärungen herumschlagen mussten was
häufig vorkommt
[Musik]
viermal pro jahr verkauft das
auktionshaus online alles erdenkliche
aus dem besitz reicher leute von
kostbarem über nützliches bistums und
seltenen liebhaberobjekt hier habe ich
eine abhandlung über mathematik
wer nach p g hat ihnen zwölf jahren in
denen er das auktionshaus und führt
unterschiedliche erfahrungen mit
erbengemeinschaften gemacht
er ist überzeugt dass erben weniger
streiten wenn sie ihren nachlass zuerst
schätzen lassen
aus erfahrung weiß ich wenn mir jemand
die tür öffnet und zeigt also wissen sie
wir verstehen uns alle so gut es gibt
keine probleme da denke ich schon bevor
ich über die schwelle trete das wird
sicher nicht leicht es ist also oft so
wenn alles besser ist es scheint läuft
es nicht unbedingt gut wenn man explizit
sagen muss alles läuft dann ist das
vielleicht an der oberfläche sucht
sobald man anfängt zu graben es gibt
bilder familienschmuck das ist etwas
wert man redet zugleich über geld und
über gefühle und beides verträgt sich
nicht unbedingt gut
in diesem emotionalen streit
auszuweichen entscheiden sich manche
erben lieber zum verkauf andere müssen
verkaufen weil sie die erbschaft gar
nicht halten können
im lager des hôtel de dort lagern auch
schätze aus dem schloss dort will das
war einer der ungewöhnlichsten nachlässe
die berner piquet versteigern musste die
gesamte inneneinrichtung kam unter den
hammer
das schicksal des tattoo dort will ist
einzigartig schon nur wegen das aus
wegen der familiengeschichte wegen der
arbeit die aufgewendet werden musste
wegen der anzahl der menschen mehr
spezialisten sie beteiligt waren um
alles durchzuführen
angefangen beim katalog über die
ausstellung bis zum verkauf das chateau
dutt will liegt oberhalb von montreux
mit schönsten blick auf den genfer see
es musste alles verkauft werden was sich
darin befand
vom keller bis zum dachboden
das auktionshaus hat schätze gehoben von
denen nicht einmal die besitzer wussten
ein komplettes bühnenbild aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert wurde in einer
remise gefunden
der rest ist ein erbe der superlative
2000 quadratmeter schloss 5 nebengebäude
auf 27 hektar
[Musik]
philippe courtot will verbrachte seine
kindheit hier er arbeitete beim ikk dann
beim roten kreuz in genf und bei projekt
imis mittlerweile ist er pensioniert
vor zwei jahren ist eine stiefmutter
gestorben
wir haben mauern wackeligen dächer
fassaden deren putz blättert aber keine
mittel um das alles zu unterhalten
wir bräuchten ein vermögen für den
unterhalt die drei geschwister
beschlossen die gesamte einrichtung zu
verkaufen
alleine die inventarisierung dauerte
fast ein jahr
wir nahmen uns den dachboden vor
dort lagen massen unglaubliche dinge
auf den ersten blick ein chaos aber
tatsächlich besonderheiten und
außergewöhnliche schätze wenn ein haus
250 jahre lang von gsell und familie
bewohnt wird und die eigentümer mehr
berichten dass das problem darin besteht
dass die vorfahren nie etwas verkauft
und nur gekauft haben dann besteht
unsere erste aufgabe darin die objekte
zu sichten und zusammenzutragen
zwar ist ein solch traditionsträchtigen
erbe hoch angesehen aber für die familie
die es unterhalten muss ist es eine last
allein schon staub wischen und silber
putzen gibt viel arbeit
[Musik]
im falle der familie grau dort will war
es alles andere als einfach
sie sind in der elften generation es
dann auf den knopf zu drücken
zu sagen jetzt setzen wir den
schlusspunkt hinter die geschichte von
familie schloss das macht man nicht so
leichtfertig beschuldigt fast enough
die familie bewohnte das schloss seit
zweieinhalb jahrhunderten philipp und
sein bruder jakob tieren die familie
korrespondenz unzählige briefe ein
stammbaum gehört auch dazu
von ihren vorfahren ersten die
geschwister zwar die eindrückliche
immobilie samt emmental aber kein geld
für den unterhalt des schlosses ein fass
ohne boden
die steuern werden nach kubikmetern
berechnet es sind 12.000 nur schon um
die steuern zu bezahlen mussten sich die
erben verschulden
[Musik]
hauptproblem beim vererben von
immobilien besteht darin dass es oft das
haupt aktiv um von herrschaft ist also
sprich es ist der bagger stand war
meister wert hat im nachlass und wann
mehrere erben da sind dann ist es nicht
möglich ohne verkauf von der
liegenschaft die erbteil auszahlen
wann ein erbe die liegenschaft will
übernehmen muss die anderen auszahle und
den staat an
eine strittige fall eben oft streit
darüber wie viel wert die geschafft
[Musik]
viele elisabeth und st sind die erben
des schlosses
da ihr vater wieder geheiratet hat erben
sie nach dem tod ihrer stiefmutter
letztere vererbt ihr vermögen einer
stiftung die drei geschwister bilden
eine erbengemeinschaft sie erben zu
gleichen teilen entscheidungen müssen
sie einstimmig treffen unsere
erbengemeinschaft besteht aus drei
versuche eine schwester ein bruder und
ich wir wussten seit jeher das not wien
unsere mitte übersteigt
als wir dann tatsächlich erst das war im
januar 2014 war der verkauf unumgänglich
also wenn inhalt verkaufen und
gleichzeitig die immobilie unmöglich wir
wussten dass der verkauf des schlosses
acht bis zehn jahre dauern würde
das war uns wichtig league wie zu sein
und das schloss vorläufig unterhalten zu
gehören denn wir hatten ja keinen mittel
gehabt
daher mussten wir verkaufen was zu
verkaufen waren eigentlich das inventar
wir haben uns verschuldet um überleben
zu können
also ein vergiftetes geschenk nicht
vergiftet wie denn wir wussten seit
langem dass wir es werden würden und wir
wussten seit langem leer verkauft würde
ich benutze das wort noch einmal
unumgänglich sein
nach einem jahr im metallisierung wurden
vor der versteigerung die tore für die
öffentlichkeit geöffnet
[Applaus]
das schloss war vorher nicht zugänglich
gewesen und seine schätze noch nie zu
sehen aber niemand rechnete mit einem
solchen andrang
während der drei besuchstage drängten
sich 15.000 menschen ins schloss areal
ich bin in diese menschenmenge
eingetaucht damit tausende hände
geschüttelt
ich traf einige freund aus kindertagen
einige koryphäen denen schon begegnet
war
aber ich spürte eine große menschliche
wärme die leute die kamen nur als
besucher oder und zu kaufen oder beides
waren wirklich sehr offen und herzlich
zu uns sie haben unsere situation
verstanden
das heißt dass wir verkaufen mussten das
verstanden sie sehr gut
es war auch ein bisschen ihr schloss die
familie hätte es gerne gesehen wenn ihr
erbe verschloss und das gesamte inventar
an die öffentliche hand gegangen wären
sie versuchten mit allen mitteln museen
zu interessieren aber weder die behörden
noch die museen fanden eine verwendung
die einen solchen erwerb gerechtfertigt
hätte es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass
das tattoo dort will und der park eines
tages unglücklicherweise in ausländische
hände überm wald und das macht uns sehr
traurig bis 17 grad trifft es im
september 2015 fand die versteigerung
der einrichtung statt alle 1600 objekte
des schlosses liegen für über vier
millionen franken weg das war vier mal
mehr als der tiefste geschätzte wert es
wäre uns wichtig dass die von unseren
ahnen über elf generationen angehäuften
güter bei aufgeklärten menschen landen
aber vor allem in museen und wir haben
die gewissheit wegen unserer schenkungen
an verschiedene museen dass diese
erinnerung verbaut
[Musik]
es stimmt ich ging als die versteigerung
zu ende war mit drei oder vier objekten
weil ich die mir am herzen lagen
ein siegelring den meiner vorfahren
trugen eine uhr eine sehr hübsche
taschenuhr und ein oder zwei bilder die
mein großvater ein sonntags maler gemalt
hat
das ist in etwa alles die erinnerungen
sind letztlich wichtiger für mich als
die objekte ich bin überzeugt dass ich
einen punkt in meinem leben erreicht
habe wo man sich eher befreit was ich zu
beladen
ich habe eine reiche ernte im herzen und
dem kopf die ich tief in mir bewahren
werde und kein bedürfnis nach
gegenständen
heute ist das komplette inventar bilder
und möbel versteigert oder verschenkt in
diesem katalog sind diejenigen objekte
auf geführt die die geschwister dem
museum von ihm geschenkt haben
philippe courtot viel geht davon aus
dass es noch jahre dauern wird bis das
schloss verkauft sein wird sein
schätzwert beträgt im moment 60
millionen franken nicht so einfach so
ein erbe zu verkaufen
die geschichte von über zweieinhalb
jahrhunderten wiegt schwer
[Musik]
schloss erbe zu sein ist schon selten
ein karussell zu erben ist ebenfalls
ziemlich ungewöhnlich das karussell von
uschi ist in lausanne eine institution
von jamal verlor ihren mann 2012er
betrieb dieses karussell und sie hat
hart darum gekämpft dieses erbe für sich
die re4 kinder zu erhalten
[Musik]
es hat fanta vier jahre gekostet um
zurück zu bekommen was ihrem mann
gehörte aber es ist ihr nicht gelungen
alles für ihre kinder zu retten
[Musik]
marien und leute sind die kinder von
fanta und jack marshall aus erster ehe
hat van giau freddy als jack erfuhr dass
er krank sei
verfasste er ein testament um alle seine
kinder zu bedenken
unglücklicherweise unterschrieb er es
nicht und gab dieses unfertige also
ungültige testament seiner frau er gab
mir den umschlag aber ich sagte damals
das ist nicht das wichtigste du musst
dich jetzt erst mal pflegen
dann habe ich den umschlag und legte ihn
in den safe der bank was er geschrieben
hatte habe ich nicht gelesen
die marshalls kontaktierten loren ruf
sie sollte van giau und ihren kindern zu
ihrem recht verhelfen
es ging um immobilien ein karussell und
um peter loos hatte vor seinem ableben
seine letztwillige verfügung
aktualisieren lassen was er ja auch tat
womit er aber nicht fertig geworden ist
er hätte ein neues testament aufsetzen
müssen indem es klar heißt ich will das
karussell meine frau die peter loos
meinen kindern die immobilien dem und
dem 5 etwas das klarer wäre als das was
er damals verfasste
das problem ist dass jack maréchal 1997
vor der geburt seine kinder schon ein
testament verfasst hatte darin vermachte
er seine pedalos einem damaligen
angestellten und sein vermögen seiner
schwester
seine frau und die kinder haben dieses
alte testament angefochten
das war wie ein messer in den wir
wussten nichts davon es kam aus dem
nichts
es gab diesen streit mit papas schwester
die im nachhinein auftauchte und die
also es war wirklich es gab keine
geldprobleme
es war eher emotional es war krass im
fernsehen sieht man wie schlimm das sein
kann
aber ich dachte nicht dass uns das
passiert aber es passiert oft von cha
und ihre kinder kämpfen vor gericht um
die pedale firma des ehemannes und
vaters während der dauer des verfahrens
verloren sie jedoch die konzession und
das bewirtschaftungs recht für die boote
[Musik]
ich habe das gefühl es war ein anderes
leben
es ist schon so lange her seit wir hier
spielt mir scheint als wäre es gestern
gewesen
diese firma gehörte meinem papa er war
28 jahre her bevor statt
sie gehörte ihm eine firma die er selbst
aufgebaut hat als kinder führt mehr hier
die kasse halfen die pedalos
anzuschieben
wir waren immer sehr motiviert ich
glaube einer von uns vieren hätte die
firma weitergeführt ich meine
niemand kennt sich da besser aus als wir
wir sind damit groß geworden
mein bruder hätte weiter gemacht und ich
hätte ihm geholfen meine mutter hatte
viele ideen
selbst wenn wir die firma nicht behalten
hätten hätten wir alle lust gehabt uns
darum zu kümmern
es ist das was mein vater geschaffen hat
er hat alles für unsere zukunft
aufgebaut
er hat das gemacht damit wir eine firma
haben damit wir diese goldgrube behalten
können keine sorgen haben müssen
er wusste er würde eines tages sterben
[Musik]
die geschichte ist hochkomplex der
ehemalige mitarbeiter die schwester des
vaters die kinder die friedensrichter
bestellte einen treuhänder der das erbe
verwaltete zum großen leidwesen der
familie
sie stand vor dem nichts und hätte gerne
weitergemacht
[Musik]
der verwalter wurde ernannt weil die
verwaltung der erbschaft schwierig war
es war ein geschäft da das geführt
werden musste die pedalos und das
karussell mussten bewirtschaftet werden
es war nichts was die erben einfach so
fortsetzen konnten
man wüsste nicht welcher er wäre das
geschäft übernehmen würde
während der wartezeit musste man
maßnahmen ergreifen auch hinsichtlich
der gebäude die renoviert wird mussten
die rolle eines offiziellen verwalters
besteht darin auf den erhalt des erbes
zu achten damit es nicht an wert
verliert bis zu dem moment wo es
zwischen den erben aufgeteilt wird
die leute wollen oft nicht dass man sich
in ihre angelegenheiten mischt
[Musik]
schließlich haben sie einen ausweg
gefunden die verschiedenen erben haben
sich geeinigt und eine vereinbarung zur
erbteilung unterzeichnet von cha und
ihren kindern wurde das karussell
zugesprochen
sie betreiben ist noch heute die pedalos
allerdings bekamen sie nicht
der bootsverleih wird heute von einem
anderen unternehmer geführt
vier jahre lang haben sie sich um das
erbe gestritten
[Musik]
die wenigsten menschen setzen sich gerne
mit dem eigenen tod auseinander
das würde auch erklären weshalb viele
menschen kein testament verfassen
nur rund ein drittel der verstorbenen
hinterlässt überhaupt ein testament
dieses schafft nicht immer klarheit
da wisse dass wir verpflichtet sind alle
testament wo ich greift werde zu
eröffnen und zwar egal ob die gültig
sind oder auf kuba oder was auch immer
und schwierigkeit wenn mehrere testament
gereicht werden besteht häufig dort hin
dass nicht klar ist es dass jetzt gilt
wann zum beispiels datum vergessen
worden ist oder was man oft erlaubt ist
das meer im testament bezug auf das
anders testament nimmt und dann eine
ganz klar ich lande sich widersprachen
was jetzt gilt
auch wenn der nachlass gültig und klar
geregelt wurde sind nicht alle probleme
aus der welt
auch er verträge haben tücken große
shooting betreibt eine kleine papeterie
die genferin hat sich hier ihre bunte
welt geschaffen
vielleicht auch um eine dunkle
geschichte zu vergessen
[Musik]
meine eltern haben sich scheiden lassen
als ich 20 jahre alt war
mein vater hat wieder geheiratet ich war
erwachsen als er erneut heiratete eine
junge frau die jünger war als er mit ihr
hat er nochmals zwei kinder
der vater von france was versucht er
alles um die neue familie finanziell
möglichst gut abzusichern
[Musik]
mein vater und seine frau wollten ihre
angelegenheiten regeln
sie beschlossen mich einen erbvertrag
unterschreiben zu lassen durch den das
gesamte erbe an den überlebenden partner
gehen sollte während mein vater und
seine frau das vorbereiteten bekam ich
einige informations brocken
wir bringen die dinge in ordnung wir
wollen uns gegen ansprüche der erben
schützen
wir wollen versuchen unseren
lebensstandard zu erhalten auch wenn
einer von uns stirbt dass ich ja
verstehen kann was blieb ihnen und ihrer
schwester den kindern aus erster ehe
nach diesem vertrag mit dieser idee
nicht viel eigentlich gar nichts vor
allem dann wenn mein vater als erster
sterben würde
franc und ihre schwester würden laut
gesetz die hälfte des väterlichen
vermögens erben der vorgeschlagenen
vertrag würde die zweite ehefrau
begünstigen und die kinder aus erster
ehe zwingen auf ihr erbe ihren
pflichtteil zu verzichten
[Musik]
rockig ist der name seit ein vertrag
zwischen mehreren in der regel mehrere
beteiligte zum der zukünftig nachlassen
oder für alle beteiligten dem erbvertrag
zugleich
der vertrag ist bindend und gott jedem
sportler errichtete testament vor
also hatte stärkere bierkrieg dann das
taten sie als sie den vertrag gelesen
haben in dem augenblick traf mich fast
der schlag es war als ob mir die decke
auf den kopf fallen würde das war zu
viel
mir war völlig unverständlich wie er
sich überlegen konnte uns nichts zu
hinterlassen
es war als hätte uns unser vater
vergessen
ich war so überrascht
ich versuchte fragen zu stellen ich
versuchte zu sagen aber papa du vergisst
dass du zwei töchter hast
allein die tatsache dass ich diese
fragen stellte sorgte dafür dass mein
vater die türen verschloss die
verwandtschaft die familie das ist für
mich heilig ich habe meinen vater nicht
verstoßen
er hat mich verstoßen ohne das opfer zu
spielen habe ich weiter gelebt ich hatte
glück mit meinem umfeld das für mich da
war es um die schwester haben den
vertrag nicht unterschrieben
nach dem tod des vaters erwartete sie
aber nochmals eine böse überraschung
die zweite frau hatte geld in das haus
des vaters investiert er schenkte ihr
dieses haus behielt aber die schulden
die schulden vermehrten sich mit den
jahren diese erbten nun france und ihre
schwester darum blieb ihnen nichts
anderes übrig als die erbschaft
auszuschlagen
das war inakzeptabel
das konnte ich nicht ich hatte keine
mitglied war daher gezwungen auch auf
das wie soll ich sagen künstlerische
erbe meines vaters zu verzichten
ich male selbst ich sage ihnen das ist
nicht leicht
was hätten sie gern behalten von ihrem
vater einmal die agonie einem bleistift
zum beispiel nur radiergummi und
bleistift bekam nichts nichts das wäre
toll gewesen nur als erinnerung
[Musik]
was hat diese geschichte zutiefst
verletzt
aber auf einen rechtsstreit machte sie
sich nicht einlassen
ihr fehlte schlicht die kraft
noch immer belastet sie diese geschichte
um ihr erbe
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert vom toyota
yaris dem kleinsten vollhybrid
[Musik]